What LingQ does, LingQ is a
tool, it's like training wheels.
It gets you to a point where
you can now read a book and
not have to look things up.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about why books
are so important in language learning.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
Books.
What do I mean by books?
Paper books.
All right.
Now you may be surprised to hear me say
that books are so important and, but I'll
tell you why I think they're important
and the role of the computer, or, you
know, iPhone, iPad, LingQ in language or
anything, and how that fits in with books.
First of all, it's also a matter
of personal preference, but if I
have a book like this, you know,
I'm not going to be distracted.
All right.
I can't go and check my Twitter feed.
Um, there's no lights coming at me.
I'm just sort of connecting with,
with whatever is written in this
book, uh, background of paper
that hopefully isn't glossy.
I find that very comfortable.
I enjoy doing that.
I think there is research to show
that we learn better reading from a
traditional source like this, rather
than reading on a screen, even on an
iPhone screen or a computer screen.
So that's one thing, it's comfortable.
The second thing about books is that
it's so important in our language
learning activity, in terms of the
content that we use, in terms of the
different activities that we have in
terms of the different ways, you know,
we approach sometimes the same material
is very important to have a variety.
So I like books and I like books
where I'm able to access some of
the material that I've been studying
at LingQ on my iPad, for example.
So the function of the, uh, of
LingQ specifically is to get us to
a stage where we can read a book.
In fact, the origin of LingQ was that I
was reading books in Spanish and German,
and constantly coming across words that
I didn't know, and I would underline
them and make lists and look them up.
And then I would stop looking
them up and I would forget them.
And it was just very inefficient.
What LingQ does, LingQ is a
tool, it's like training wheels.
It gets you to a point point
where you can now read a book
and not have to look things up.
I should add that before LingQ I used
to have readers where there would be
a glossary after each lesson, but here
again, it's very distracting to be
flipping back and forth to the glossary.
The glossary may have the word that
you're looking for very often it doesn't.
On the other hand, um, words they
have on their glossary, most of them
are words you already know, because
there's no way the person who wrote
the book can anticipate which words you
know and which words you don't know.
So in a way, the, the point of LingQ is,
is to sort of bypass that stage of the
reader with, uh, with the vocabulary list
and get you to the point where you can
ignore the few words that you don't know,
because you now know 95% of the words.
So the goal with LingQ is to
make you independent of LingQ.
So, uh, I'm reminded, I think there
was a parable by Zhuangzi the Taoist,
Chinese philosopher, who said something
about, uh, once the fishermen needs
the fish trap to catch the fish.
And once he's got the fish, he
doesn't need the fish trap anymore.
And then he went on to...
I can't remember what it was, but
it's a typical cryptic, uh, parable.
Uh, I need words for me and
once I have the meaning, I
don't need the words anymore.
Something to that effect.
I should've looked it up.
In fact, I may just go look for it.
Link to it from the description
box, but the point is LingQ is
that kind of a, a fish trap.
It's to get you to a level where
you can read in books, because
to me that is the most enjoyable
way to engage with the language.
Reading is for acquiring vocabulary.
Uh, but listening, as I've said
before, is to get used to the language.
And even there, you don't want to
always have to rely on LingQ to
understand what you're listening to.
You want to get to the point, I want to
get to the point where I can just go in
there, pick up my podcast, understand it
all, uh, watch a movie, understand it all.
So LingQ is sort of a range of tools
to get, to get you to a point where you
can enjoy the language, the way native
speakers enjoy the language and, and a
goal should be to be able to read books.
You know, I think to myself, you
know, if, if for whatever reason, the
technology around MP3 files and audio
recording and so forth had come first
before writing, and then all of a
sudden someone discovered the ability
to, you know, with the sort of short
annotation system, writing system to
record what people are saying on paper.
Let's say we didn't have paper.
We didn't have means of writing.
And all of a sudden we have it, uh,
you know, would that, would people
have been interested in that or
would they just rely on, on audio?
Because after all, historically
it was the storytellers who, um,
you know, kept literature alive.
So if you didn't have to write
things down and you could record it,
would that mean you didn't need it?
And I personally would still
be interested in reading.
I think it's a wonderful, uh, activity
for the brain to read the symbols and
to convert these symbols into meaning.
It's, it's a very demanding thing to do.
It's a, quite a different type of
activity than, uh, listening to something.
And I find that activity is most
pleasant when it is on paper, as opposed
to sort of this active screen with
the temptation to fly off elsewhere.
So whenever I see books, um, you
know, intended for learners of the
language and eventually books, you
know, intended for native speakers,
I have a tendency to buy these.
You'll see all the books behind me.
I've got so many of these books.
Surprisingly, most of them I have
read, but many I haven't yet read.
And nowadays they are getting
a little better, you know, so
I bought these books on Arabic.
Uh, one series is put...
I don't have the other one here,
but one is put out by Yale and
they have a place where you can go
online and get the audio recording.
Unfortunately, they don't give you,
you can't download the audio file.
You can just listen to it online.
I can listen to it on my
iPad while I exercise in the
morning, but I can't download it
.
Also, they don't give
you the electronic text.
And that would, of course enable
me to save words and phrases so I
could import it to LingQ, go through
it with my training wheels on, at
LingQ, acquire the words and phrases.
And then again, read it in the book,
which is sort of reinforcing it, doing,
covering the same material, but in a
different format, which is a conventional
paper book, but they don't do that.
And that's been my experience elsewhere
that books like this, they will never
facilitate the learning of the language
through their material by enabling you to
access, uh, eText or download audio files.
However, another one, ah, here
we are this one, uh, because
I'm into Egypt and Arabic.
So I found this other series that is
put out by the university of Cairo.
And they've got a tremendous
range, uh, number of audio
files, which I can download.
Uh, I, I can't access the, uh,
eText for these, uh, lessons, but I
have ordered the books from Amazon.
So I'm going to be listening
to the Egyptian Arabic audio
files, and then I'll be looking
forward to reading them on paper.
Not ideal because as I say, they, the
goal is to read on paper, but I need the
training wheels to get my vocabulary up
to a level where I can enjoy the books.
So I think I sent them an email
saying, can I, any way you could
send me the Etext for these,
but I don't expect to hear back.
Cause every time I, uh, emailed these
publishers, I also emailed the Yale, uh,
bookstore and said any way I can get the
eText and the audio files, and I don't
expect to hear back, but even without
that, I find it very enjoyable to read
books in the languages that I'm learning.
Even if I have to devise strategies and,
and search for resources online, uh, to
power me up to a point where I can really,
you know, enjoy those books, but enjoying
books, real books printed on paper is
not only a goal, but I think it takes you
to that next level in language learning.
So I don't think that electronic
books, Kindles, e-books are going
to make, uh, paper books disappear.
So I wanted to talk a bit about why
books are important in language learning
as well as reading for enjoyment.
Bye for now.